67 votos a favor y 27 en contra joe
biden está a punto de entrar en lo que
él llama el siglo americano su plan de
1.2 billones de dólares de inversiones
en infraestructuras acaba de ser avalado
por los senadores fue el resultado de
complicadas negociaciones y de un raro
consenso entre demócratas y republicanos
se trata de un compromiso que
republicanos y demócratas tienen una
visión radicalmente diferente hoy en día
pero estamos de acuerdo en que hay que
crear infraestructuras que funcionen
para todos nuestros ciudadanos
este plan calcula 550 mil millones de
dólares en nuevos gastos federales
cuando 450 mil millones de fondos ya
están atribuidos a otras partidas el
objetivo modernizar los equipos antiguos
como carreteras puentes puertos y
aeropuertos pero también renovar los
circuitos de agua potable y de
electricidad y por fin invertir en el
internet de alta velocidad
joe biden ve las cosas en grande y se
felicita de ver este
acto de ley en buen camino este acuerdo
representa una inversión histórica no
podemos permitirnos no hacerlo un paso
decisivo acaba de ser superado
falta someter el texto a la cámara de
representantes donde los demócratas
controlan la mayoría un voto final
favorable podría significar una gloriosa
victoria para el presidente yo bailé